this episode is presented by super cards
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts
after the honest trailer check out the
honest theme song and music video we
made for the batman link in the
description below
[Music]
dang i wish movie soundtracks were still
a big deal also dang why can't i sing
like that
[Music]
in a world of corruption and chaos the
people cry out for a hero who can join
them in the darkness
darker than that even darker
darker
that's just a black screen
there we go
nice
the batman
watch robert pattinson with the final
stake in his twilight sparkle and give
us the first truly gen z version of
batman his villains are influencers hey
guys
uh thanks for all the comments he's
worse off than his parents this
continues it won't be long before you've
nothing i don't care about that and his
hometown will very soon be underwater
he's ready to put the goth back in
gotham a city that's one part new york
and now eight part seattle
in this puddle of sin hunts the riddler
a guy who talks a big game about
cleaning up the city for someone dressed
like a garbage bag he'll do more to stop
corruption than batman ever has with
nothing but a roll of duct tape
a barista's sense of flare and the most
hardcore followers ever he's been
posting online he's got like 500
followers real fringe types how is it
that his videos get 500 dudes to do
terror stuff but might get barely 10
percent of you to like and subscribe
what do you want from me riddles murders
movie fights
experience the first batman who's both
psychologically vulnerable and
physically invincible
oh that's gonna leave a mark
ah no just gonna walk it off okay but
what this batman really wants to do is
detect watch the world's not quite
greatest detective decode ciphers thanks
to his butler i've taken the liberty of
doing a little
work on this latest cipher solve riddles
thanks to gotham's finest convention
with a freaking carpet tool it's a
a tanker and kills however many truck
drivers it takes to answer the mystery
who is elrotta vada the rat with wings
hmm let me think here a rat with wings
that could be anyone the penguin falcone
batman no it's too obvious ooh black
canary maybe night owl
oh no where's robin
join batman in the second year in the
job so it's not just a face okay dad oh
you're not my father but before he had
the justice league bruce was stuck
working with the gotham police mustache
division featuring james gordon a man
doing his best to get fired by bringing
a weird fetish goth to every crime scene
whoa whoa
are you kidding me sir you gonna let him
in here i got the press downstairs he's
a goddamn vigilante he could be a
suspect you're really okay with this
what about chain of evidence don't have
your other friends like him gordon stop
inviting him to parties plus an assist
from alfred who gave director matt
reeves his greatest performance ever and
was rewarded with the role of guy caught
in the blast radius and catwoman a
bi-motorcycle burglar with lots of cats
and daddy issues
perfection i mean i have no notes
together they'll take on cd underworld
types like falcone who finally got
around to teaching people how to
pronounce his name falcone paid him off
just stood up to falcone head of the
falcone crime family falcone is the red
a version of colin farrell so gross it
almost ruins his sex tape and a
city-wide conspiracy to loot the wayne's
charity fund for evil selling bruce
could have stopped by showing up to his
day job like once our accounting friends
at wayne enterprises are coming for
breakfast i haven't got time for this
there's no time alfred some brown
teenagers are playing the knockout game
now hand me my stun glove
so enjoy a really really really
ridiculously good looking batman movie
which was necessary since it's also a
really really really ridiculously long
batman movie
as we bask in the latest era of dc where
they just let good filmmakers stick a
thug in front of the name and have their
way with it until warner brothers does
their usual executive shuffle thing and
i don't know crams a joker into
everything again
oh come on
starring
gerard wayne thundercats oh
the right man for the job crime ally
incelsior
the vague lebowski
the tumbler
colin farrow watching the old daredevil
movies holy god what are you showing
around his head come on
caves together strong
martinez that guy is the homie and druix
sucks
the twinite saga
man memories really blew a chance to
show us what it looked like when the
wings were killed i mean just imagine
gun being raised young bruce's trembling
face martha's pearls falling to the
ground someone should really put that on
film one day
thanks for watching and if you've made
it this far why not keep the bad dance
going by checking out our honest theme
song for the batman click the thumbnail
on the right to watch now
this episode was presented by supercards
the smarter easier way to get a haircut
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts check in today on our mobile app or
supercuts.com
bryston beats the bad guys better so
gentleman you can't fight in here this
is the war room